[Musique]
concert via méritée pour les 6000
coureurs qui ont donné tout ce qu'ils
avaient si certains enfilent leurs
chaussures de course pour se maintenir
en santé
sa garde en forme puis ça cultive les
amitiés d'autres le feront simplement
pour le plaisir
c'était vraiment le forte il ya beaucoup
d'actions telles bonnes
plus de 5000 personnes ont pris part aux
épreuves du 5 et du 10 km des coureurs
d'ici d'ailleurs et de tous âges qui
lobait pour certains la course n'a plus
de secret j'ai déjà couru dans plusieurs
courses avec ma maman je fais plusieurs
courses e à des endroits différents
est-ce que pas un objectif pour cette
course y arriver premier
les épreuves les plus importantes le
marathon il demi marathon auront lieu
demain
quinze mille coureurs sont attendus y
compris des professionnels ayant une
quinzaine de coureurs d'élite alors ils
sont comment c'est arrivé jeudi dernier
lors du kenya et de l'afrique
c'est toujours impressionnant moi c'est
ma deuxième année que je les accueille
et j'en viens pas les arts qui font ils
la relève semble assurée
cette fois tous repartent avec une
médaille montre est et avec beaucoup de
fierté
i think i caouette radio-canada à
montréal
[Musique]